[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young man
who wants to mend his relationship with
his dad we also talked to a woman who is
pregnant and struggling with sugar
addiction
we talked to a woman who's married to a
man with bipolar disorder and she wants
to know how to live inside the chaos
stay tuned
[Music]
what is up this is john with the dr john
dolone show so glad you're with us on a
rainy rainy day in nashville
hope the sun is shining wherever you are
it's not too cold not too hot if it's
just right
i guess this is the goldilocks show too
gosh i
i'm trying to level this thing up and
every time
i think i'm that much of a dork
whatever james good to see you jenna
filling in for the one and only
you are the new one and only it's good
to see you
you make my heart feel good and james
with the uh
the mic the headphone extension today
that was huge that was huge after two
years you thought
i'm gonna love him that much will you
tell everybody what my favorite part of
the headphone extension was
that you have to
no like sit on it the right way is that
should be no that's the old way my
favorite is
when you said and i quote i've had this
in my drawer i thought this might help
the number of meetings we've had about
your awesome james
it's awesome thank you for caring about
us
america if you want to know what does a
producer do that
they they think about ideas for i don't
know a couple of years
and they think now's the time
it's time to time to pull it out of the
drawer
and jenna huge
for our first call up here you put what
country they're from
that was big time i hadn't thought of
that and um i always get confused and
that was huge jenna thank you so much so
we're gonna go to steven in greenville
south carolina united states of america
what's up stephen
how you doing today i'm good my brother
how are you
i'm good uh i know you're probably
excited about this that poetic win by uh
oliveira over poise on the weekend
was not very uh poetic man
but hey i gotta i will i'll call it what
it is guy's good man guy's real good
and uh
poi is real good too man it's that's
tough to get foyer to roll over and
man hats off to oliveira who are you
rooting for
uh i was uh i was rooting for oliver you
would you would stephen that's all right
what's up dude
uh so i'm calling in uh trying to figure
out how to mend a relationship my dad's
in a
relationship with somebody that's i
don't know if you'd say half his age
more than half his age or less than half
his age
and how how old is that person
in relation to you are you all the same
age
no they're
seven years older than me my dad's 71
they're 30.
you're 23
yes sir
is that weird
it is um
she has a five-year-old daughter in the
situation as well okay
so
yeah man you and i could hang out and
have a beer and talk about this for a
long time so
what's your question
uh what's the best way to mend that
because additionally to that he said
that he has the family that he's always
wanted
oh man that's
way to go dad
um so when you say men tell me more
about that
so uh
well
i'm on a speaking term with him okay
i'll go see him for his birthday we'll
meet up for lunch
on my birthday
but uh i guess another additional part
of this question would be that my sister
hasn't really spoken to him in two years
because
that was a big fallout with them so just
the whole
family ordeal i'm the only one that goes
over for christmas and like i said
birthdays and stuff yeah and we'll talk
on the phone occasionally but it doesn't
extend past that have you done something
that violated your dad's trust in you
um i haven't have you done something
that
um
i was would violate the values that a
son like the respect and dignity a son
gives to his dad
no sir because when all this started we
actually had a business where we were
working together and then that was the
fall out of that as well
so the heartbreaking thing here brother
is this your dad chose a new family
and there's nothing you can mend here
because you didn't break it
right
and
for whatever reason
your old man has decided
to cut ties from
his original
family and to create a new one and
whether it's in his head or whether he's
trying to relive something
by
hooking up with somebody 40 years
younger than him
like whatever it happens to be
um
unfortunately man it's not your not only
is it not your job you can't
pay me a picture of what you wish it
would look like
i mean just more of
more inclusive where we can actually go
down go out with him have a dinner or
something but he told you he wants
the other family
right
why why don't you have dinner with him
is he like a jerk when you all are out
together does he say no all the time is
he like some kind of racist bigot idiot
like
what are the things that keep you all
from getting together
well
um ever since they've gotten into a
relationship he's become
i guess you'd say vulgar like he chooses
to cuss a lot i get
mad at things that
aren't a big deal like uh on my birthday
we were just sitting there eating
because where we happened to go was
closed on the inside so we sat
in the vehicle and ate and he saw
somebody walking up didn't like the way
they liked got upset about i'm kind of
mad about that and it's just he's
changed so it's not a
not the
enjoyable guy he used to be
what changed in him like what happened
i don't know ever since this
relationship it's uh it's like he's
always on edge and
his favorite line he likes to go to is
because i mean a lot of people don't
talk to him as much as they used to his
favorite line he likes to say is that
nobody ever asks him if he's happy but
he's happy now and he just keeps saying
that over and over and over almost like
he's trying to convince himself
exactly yes sir oh man
so here's what you got to do
um and you've heard me say this a
thousand times you're gonna have to
process this and grieve this
any relationship with your dad
there's a picture in your head of what
you would love to see and it's not gonna
happen
unless your dad gets struck by lightning
and has this moment where he's like what
am i doing
and um
unfortunately you see this happen all
the time all the time all the time did
you have a lot of money by the way uh
not that i'm aware of
[Laughter]
well
maybe this 30 year old your your this 30
year old new wife of his looked up and
just like i i love seven-year-old men
and um this is my ride maybe that maybe
that's it um
bam but you're gonna have to have this
picture you're gonna have to grieve it
you have to say this isn't
what my life is beared out and this
isn't what it we drew it up is what we
wanted this is what we deserve man we
deserve a dad that loves us and wants to
talk to us and wants to be with her
they're kids
um you didn't get that man and i'm
heartbroken for you
and then the next thing to do is to live
in a picture that's reality
and
this is all you can control is what's
going forward and my you know i
recommend this all the time i'd
recommend you write them a letter you
probably aren't going to send it
get that stuff out
and then sit with your sister and say
what what are we working through and
then i'd find a couple of other men who
are older than you in age and connect
with those dudes
and maybe it's the first season maybe
they break up in a year two and he comes
back to you and says what in the world
is i doing and then you get to walk down
the road of forgiveness and
reconnection all that but he's gone
through the reconnecting
you're just his son
and you've treated him with dignity with
respect and you continue to and he's
chosen a different path and he's
i can't imagine looking at my two little
kids and saying finally i get the family
i wanted i can't even wrap my head
around that even sound honest
that sounds like a hurting old man he's
trying to make sense of his place
sorry brother
i wish i had better news for you man
you're a good man keep being a good man
keep treating people dignity and respect
we'll see you soon
be right back on the dr john dolani show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can
actually breathe because you got an
expert in a team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back and hey before we
take the next call i'd like to publicly
apologize for being mean to james
off air he said i need you to apologize
to me publicly
that's not true number one number two
you just ruined the apology
i'd like to apologize to james
he did for a couple years have this cord
in his desk that has made my day better
he did
and he did choose to not even think to
give it to me
but
today he did think of it and i need i
need to i can't i got to own the past
i got to live in the present
and um i'm going to choose to be
grateful moving forward so james thanks
for thinking of me
you're not even gonna respond to that
just gonna nod gently all right let's go
to sarah in wichita kansas what's up
sarah
there you are what's up
sorry don't be sorry what are you up to
oh just waiting to go to work
excellent
so what's up how can i help you this
morning
well i was wondering how
i can
stop my sugar addiction
and if it's too late for my kids to
not foul in the same
steps as me
you realize you're you
basically what you just did was you're
like hey i am an active cocaine user and
you went to the dealer to ask how to
break your addiction
sarah i'm an addict too so it's good to
talk to you my name is john and i too
have a problem
so tell me about your sugar addiction
that's why i called oh thanks for
kicking them down hey so um what are you
uh tell me what's going on
um basically i
i have a lot of stress and i use
my stress as well i use sugar to
basically cope with my
stress um tell me about your stress
um
i have a nine-year-old that has a lot of
behavioral problems
he's
he's a great kid
we just
there's some sort of disconnection there
that we
my husband and i
just can't seem to figure out
and i am a
definitely a fixer i'm trying to
constantly trying to figure out who to
take him to next
as far as a doctor or a therapist and it
just
we don't really get anywhere so
that's
what about before that how's your
marriage
i'm good um
my husband and i have been married for
five years yeah um
my son was from a previous marriage um i
have a nine-year-old and an
eight-year-old from a previous marriage
um
and then i have a three-year-old and a
baby on the way so okay
you have people
everywhere is your nine-year-old still
in communication with dad
no um he gave up all rights
and my husband adopted him in february
of this year that's awesome
how long so i guess three or four years
you were single mom in it
um no
actually i my ex-husband left me in 2015
and i met my husband at the end of 2015
online okay
and then
moved from ohio to kansas um
from november to
july of 2016 we got married so
pretty quickly
but he's a wonderful complete opposite
of my ex-husband and sure he's just
he's really great so
um i want you to try something this
isn't why you called but i want you to
give something a shot will you take a
30-day shot at something for me
yeah
um
for 30 days i want you and your husband
to be a part of this i want both of you
to contribute to this okay
okay um that nine-year-old of yours
i want you in the morning
to
let him know he has to have a 30 second
hug with you
okay and i want you to put your bare
hands on the back of his bare neck
okay and your husband has to do it too
his dad
30 seconds
and then when he gets right when he gets
home from school you have to do it again
and then right before bed you have to do
it again
okay so that's three solid minutes of
hand-to-hand hugging a day
for 30 days
one other thing
one of y'all has to go for a walk with
him
every day
it could be a short walk it could be a
long walk whatever
if you do this for 30 days
i may be out to lunch and on mars
that i would be stunned if there wasn't
a dramatic decrease in
spin-up with your nine-year-old
most of the
my guess is this
he's on high alert for
connection
yeah
is that fair
yeah yeah
um give that a shot it may be a complete
waste of time and if it is you've hugged
your kid for 30 days that's there's no
loss there my guess is i've seen it have
dramatic effects
um even when you got it you're like oh
crap
and you gotta you forget and you gotta
go back and be like hold on we gotta get
our morning hug
and it feels like a chore do it anyway
and tell your tell your husband no side
hugs front hugs only okay so how do you
cut out sugar addiction
two things have helped okay one you may
have heard me talk about i don't even
know if this episode's aired i had um
working with a guy named dr gus vickery
out of
north carolina he's a savant he's maybe
the best doctor i've ever sat down i
know he's the best doctor very sit down
and he's he's extraordinary human
um
he did
the most extensive blood work on me
genetic testing and then he
walked me through everything
he said i've got something they call the
cookie jar gene meaning if it's open in
my house i'm gonna demolish it
and he said you probably have seasons
where i can grit it and have really
remarkable willpower i also have
something else i don't remember when
it's sniper gene or military gene
i've got a darkness in me too i'll say
that sarah um
i can do hard things
um but my tendency is always gonna pull
back to
just polishing off the whole bag of
whatever's there
and
i started doing my own like i kept a
small journal
when was i reaching for this stuff and
for me 100 of the time when i would just
mindlessly reach for candy cookies
whatever
had something relational
going on whether it was a relationship
at work whether it was i'd find myself
telling my wife about something that
happened with a co-worker and then boom
i'm reaching for something um my son
would come in and say something i'd get
frustrated and i'd respond in a way i
didn't like and then my wife and i were
talking about i'd be grabbing for
something or with my daughter or my wife
and i get frustrated and i'd leave my
room and then i'd go to the straight to
the fridge
every single thing was relational in
nature
i've also
heard um
uh seen the scene a few studies i don't
know i don't know how great the studies
are but they make sense to me that
fatigue being tired or exhausted your
body is looking for quick prop up energy
and so it just directs you towards the
cheapest calorie i can find which is
often oreos or doritos
um either of those sound
up your alley
exactly to a tea and i'm 32 weeks
pregnant so the exhaustion definitely is
there okay but yeah i mean
it's it feels like
in the morning i'm i'm fine
yeah i'll eat junk food but then i think
oh yeah i'll just walk it off because i
have all day to walk it off
but it doesn't happen and then by the
time i get off work get home it's like
i don't know it's like a
i just
feel like i'm in that mood that bad mood
constantly and i
i don't want to take it out on my kids
but
i just go and eat junk food instead
which you know this ultimately takes it
out on your kids right yeah oh yeah um
it's just got a longer tail to it
so i want you to work on a few things
and some of these are going to be easier
than others
the first one is this
this may be a hard conversation you have
with your husband
it may be a hard conversation you have
with a counselor it may be a hard
conversation you have with all three
with with i mean with yourself and with
counselor and husband
why isn't home a place of safety and
shoulders dropping
what is it about home
that amps your body up
and what i want you to begin to do is
solve for peace in your house
and some of those things were like i we
implemented in my house like i had to be
able to walk in the door i'd walk in and
my kids were all every day
dad can i have a snack can i have candy
cane because my wife had said no
and so we actually implemented no
questions
we have hugs when i walk in and then i
go in my room and it gives me 10 seconds
to toggle and that ended up being enough
but i needed i needed to be very
tactical about what is it about my house
that's not safe
i also
gotten this weird thing where i'd come
home and i we have one of these open
houses and i could see my wife across
the she'd be doing something in the
kitchen or doing something you know at
her writing area
and i would see her posture and i would
think oh she's already in a bad mood
and so then i would gently or not even a
bad mood she's just busy doing something
she doesn't want me around and so i'd
peel off and just be like i'm gonna mind
my own business and it was that moment
that there was a tiny tiny
gap between me and her
and over that evening that gap would
just grow wider and wider and wider
and then she would feel me kind of
peeling off and she'd try to reach over
and i but she'd reach a little bit more
abruptly and then i so it just created
this gap and you know what solves that
gap
oh my gosh ice cream for sure
right
and so
i committed to not putting words into
her head
i committed to no matter how she her
body posture was
i said hey it's good to see you and we
hug right when i get home
that body
contact that body connection and it
might be a short hug it might be a long
hug depending on her day or my day but
we reach out and i lean across that
thing um that gap and she does too now
and that that's a conversation for you
and your husband what are ways we can
reconnect right when i get home that
makes my body begin to anticipate home
being a place of
ah not a place of ah right and then when
it comes to sugar
here is the
unfortunate sad
thing that you're gonna have to make
peace with in your life
scorched earth avoidance
never
or if you haven't if you have a
thanksgiving and you make all the stuff
crush it that that meal
and then make sure everybody takes
leftovers home
if you go buy a bag of candy eat the
whole thing in the car
or throw away half of it and then don't
bring it home
and that's hard on my kids it's hard on
my wife i hate it for them and that's
the world that that's the guy they
married
yeah right and so we just had to say i
can't have it in the house ever ever
ever have it in the house
um and then at work i have
usually have good boundaries and when i
don't i just fall off the wagon even
like the great folks over here who run
there's like a
lobby here at the studios and they've
got coffee and cookies when i go up to
ask for a cookie they'll ask do you
really want this you know because i've
asked them to help me be accountable and
often i'll say no but occasionally i'm
like yes and make it three
um my rule of thumb is i don't wanna
ever fall off a wagon but i don't mind
parking it every once in a while and
rolling around in the mud then i hose
myself off and get back up and go so i
wanna be intentional about it but that
starts with absolute abstinence for me
on almost every day of the week
yeah
so if you make peace with abstinence
then you go what else am i going to fill
this gap with and my hope is you begin
to fill that gap with
connectivity with
coloring with your kids with laughter
with being able to be heard say the
things like i'm frustrated right now and
i need to go for a walk but you begin to
trade some of the healthy behaviors
for oreo behaviors
and that's hard
if you are a full-blown addict like like
yours truly
i want you to do 30 days of cold nothing
nothing and if you want to wait till
after the holiday great um but 30 days
of cold nothing and the probably the
first two weeks will be two of the most
miserable weeks of your life it's awful
brutal
and the way i describe it is then it
feels like somebody peels a cataract off
of your heart and your mind and your
eyes and you can see and smell and feel
everything's better you can just get out
of bed and you've got more energy it's a
weird thing that happens
so that's my recommendation and i'd stay
away from fruit i'd stay away from all
of it um maybe some berries but for the
first 30 days i would cut it all just
give your body
a chance to go experience life without
it
and there is healing on the other side
of it it's hard it's hard it's a
lifelong journey they don't have just
like
well except in james's suite his area
with his team there's not a lot of other
groups on our
here at the studios that have like
cocaine just laying out right
um james has a bunch of weed and cocaine
laying out all over the place but most
people don't have that but they do have
cookies and marshmallows and candy bowls
everywhere all over their desks so it is
hard to quit sugar
but at the end of the day you gotta say
i'm done i'm quitting and i'm gonna set
up an environment where it's almost
impossible for me to fail i'll be right
back on the dr john delaney show
all right let me clear up a common
misconception being tired all the time
is not normal and if you're always
exhausted take a good look at your
nightly sleep routine are you scrolling
the internet for hours or sharing a bed
with 17 animals in your spouse is your
mattress older than you listen the sleep
environment you create has so much to do
with how well you rest you've got to
protect it eliminate screens skip late
night snacks and have a bed you love
sleeping on like a dream cloud mattress
dream cloud is one of my favorite
mattresses because they're made of
premium sleep materials but they're half
the price of other premium brands they
also offer a 365 night trial and a
forever warranty to make sure you are a
hundred percent satisfied right now dr
john dolone's show listeners get 250
bucks off plus
399 dollars in sleep accessories like
pillows sheets you name it that's 649
in savings not to mention some deep deep
rest if your sleep routine needs
resetting check out dreamcloud's biggest
offer
ever
at
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code deloney
all right we are back and public service
announcement james does not have cocaine
or weed at his desk
he does have it like in his drawers but
not in his desk all right let's go to
sue in philadelphia what is up sue
hi sue uh hi dr john how are you i'm so
good how are you
i'm okay
um my husband has bipolar
and he tends to be manic for about a
year and then he tends to be depressed
for about a year
and we have kids
and life is really hard with the kids
when he's depressed because he doesn't
want anything to do with us and he says
dumb stuff to the kids
and when he's manic he does dumb stuff
um
we did fpu and we're on track to be out
of baby step
two next summer and he recently went and
bought a rental house
with no money because we're on baby
stuff too oh jeez so
he doesn't want any help he thinks he's
good i need help like this is taking a
toll on me physically yes i need help
for me and my kids
oh man
number one i'm sorry
number two
i'd have to go talk to some friends a
couple friends of mine who are experts
on this i've not heard of
annual cycling before
that seems like a long ramp up and a
long
ramp down
it really is and that i did
give him an ultimatum to go to a
counselor once quite a few years ago and
the counselor kind of said the same
thing but that
that is what we're seeing it's a long
time who diagnosed him
um it was a local
psychologist maybe okay i don't even
know how long
i went with him
uh that was probably nine years ago okay
it's time to go get that stuff checked
up uh well i'm gonna speak to you as
though he is somebody who's invested in
being well and then i'm because there's
you know people listening who are into
that
and into the into that into into loving
their families and taking care of
themselves and then i'm gonna
dig into the reality that you're facing
is that cool
that's cool um
somebody with a bipolar diagnosis i want
them getting reassessed every couple of
years um if not sooner than that
you should be
on meds you should have a really active
wellness plan
and you should have people in your life
that are walking alongside you
and
nine years ago no medications no
counseling no nothing is a recipe for
disaster if it's true bipolar
i
just like the counselor you met with
i've not heard off top of my head i
can't think of anyone who's i've ever
heard of who's got annual cycles like
that and for those listening who don't
know annual cycle b
normally these are two or three month
waves sometimes they're shorter than
that
i haven't heard of a wave going for 12
months low and then 12 months up
that i wonder if something else is at
play does he does he have a drug
problem too
no
so he's totally sober
and so let's deal with reality here
he won't take medication is that right
right he was depressed last year and um
he did eventually go to a counselor but
he switched counselors and he wouldn't
let me go with because he likes the
feeling of being manic so he just told
them that he was depressed and he told
them nothing about his manic speeches
so they just diagnosed him with
depression tell me about your ultimatum
um i had told him that if he didn't go
see a counselor i was going to leave him
yeah
when you say he says dumb things to the
kids what does he say
um so last year multiple times a day he
would
tell the kids that he needed them to put
his head on straight
and it really like my one daughter in
particular really took a toll on her
and no matter how much i told him that
the kids couldn't handle it he didn't
stop yeah
what prompted this call did something
happen recently
um well he bought this rental building
but i'm
i feel like i'm starting to struggle
with anxiety well yeah of course because
you're
absolutely
i mean y'all we're in the middle of an
economic mess right now and this is not
the time to be buying
house homes at their highly inflated
prices with no money down like
it's just yeah it's not a great moment
to be doing that your body is letting
you know we're not safe and you know
this
um the term we use around here with my
buddy dave
is financial infidelity
that level of deceit and
um
lack of safety and like core value
violation is a big deal if you're hiding
if you're buying things and hiding it
you're buying things that you didn't
agree on if you say hey we're in on this
plan and somebody did something
different
it's infidelity it's dishonesty it hurts
at a really deep level um what was your
post conversation when you found out
how'd that go
um
i well when it comes to fight or flight
i'm definitely slight so i just kind of
clammed up i knew it was too late there
was nothing that
i could do to stop it
so
that's kind of the point where i don't
know i'm
not really talking like he's trying to
show me how this is a good thing all the
time and
i just kind of battle up
so what's your or what
i don't know
i'm christian and i do believe
that divorce probably isn't an option
okay
i took our vows seriously but i don't
know
i don't know what options i do have
i mean you can stay or you can leave
right
so let's go with the option that you're
gonna stay
at some point you make peace with this
is who he is
we have ups and we have downs
and i'm going to put some very serious
roadblocks between me and him because
i've got to keep my family safe
okay and
that might look like
making sure like letting him know i'm
never gonna hide stuff i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna contribute to
his misbehavior
by me lessening my character right but
it may be
i need you to know i'm carrying forward
with this i'm not going to be a part of
it i don't want to be on the i mean i
don't know now you're getting to like
i'm i'm hesit as i'm speaking out loud i
don't like the words that are coming out
of my mouth let me put it this way sue
this is really bad
right
um
this
is he in a manic season right now
he is
so tell me tell me what that's like
um
he gets up at like three o'clock in the
morning
and he's going all day at work
and then he comes home and eats and
falls asleep on the couch and
that's pretty much our days and he does
whatever he wants
you don't have a marriage you know that
right
i do know that
have you met with somebody
i have not that's your step next step
okay okay
because you've got some
uh
religious values which are really
important you've got some
uh
realities can i
you're not telling me everything
about how he acts is that fair
uh
yeah maybe yeah maybe
um
there are some things going on that
aren't okay and you know that and i know
that
and you're trying to keep things held
together how old are your little ones
uh they range in age from 10 to 17. okay
that's a lot of hurt on those kids yeah
so what i want you to do is this um here
ultimately for everybody listening
you've got to get to an or what moment
either i accept the way my life is and
i'm going to be okay with it i'm going
to make peace with it i'm going to find
joy in the pockets with which i've been
dealt
or
i have an or what moment where
you will
go to counseling with me and i will have
full access to the therapy records
because your bipolar impacts all of us
you will get on some sort of medication
regimen you will get new psychometric
testing to find out where you even are
because this doesn't sound right to me
and again i'm just a podcast guy i'm not
a full-time psychologist so there you go
um
it doesn't it's not passing my initial
smell test i could be way off but it's
just not um
and he has to decide i want to love my
family
i want to love my wife i want to be
connected to them
and so in my seasons of bipolar which by
the way bipolar is super real when it's
real
i'm going to not have my atm card i am
going to not have access to our bank
accounts i'm going to not have access to
the internet or to
my vehicle or to cell phones or because
i make terrible decisions
and when i'm in slow seasons
i am going to put my lights in my
bedroom on a timer so i get up i am
going to have a
trainer that's going to show up at my
house and call me i will go see a
counselor i will take my medication so
there's things you put up put in in
in a line before these things happen
and they don't fully solve the things if
you will but they create a life that is
sustainable for the person involved and
for the family and my hypothesis is over
time
the severities begin to lessen
don't have a lot of data on that but
that's my guess you begin to practice
living in a new way
but you got to decide i want to do that
and okay you can't make him do that
that's his call
all you can do is say
i'm going to take care of me i'm going
to love me i'm going to love these kids
i'm going to make sure they know they
are loved make sure they know dad is
sick he's not well and dad's choosing to
not get well and it's not a mat it's not
a reflection of them
it's a reflection of him
and
i've got to come up with i've got to
make peace with my life or i've got to
come up with an or what moment and then
decide what's next for all of us
okay is that fair yeah at the end of the
day you can control three things
your thoughts your actions your desire
to get well and get connected that's it
and it feels powerless especially when
you're married to somebody who has no
interest in being well or changing their
life to help
themselves and the rest of the family
man i wish we could leave this on some
super hopeful high note
um
i've just seen this too much
until somebody gets invested in their
wellness
there's not a lot people can do other
than take care of themselves and also
this so you haven't taken care of soon a
long time either
and it's time you look in the mirror and
say you know what sue i'm worth it
you're worth it let's make this happen
let's take care of ourselves as we wrap
up today's show
man
james i found this dropkick murphy cd
at a ucd shop because it's uh
1971.
and dude
so great
i think it's off the
i think it's not the blackout blackout
album is that right is that the name of
the record
let me look here on the yep off the 2003
blackout
record song's called the workers song
and it goes like this
yes this one's for the workers who toil
night and day by hand and by brain to
earn your pay who for centuries long
past
for no more than your bread have bled
for your countries and counted your dead
in the factories and mills in the
shipyards and mines we've often been
told to keep up with the times for our
skills are not needed
they've streamlined the job and with
slide rule and stopwatch our pride they
have robbed we're the first ones to
starve or the first ones to die
the first one's in line for that pie in
the sky and we're always the last when
the cream is shared out for the worker
is working
when the fat cat's about
oh man
i know how that feels
working for james childs we'll see you
soon on the dr john dillon show